today of our show they are dropping like
flies or should I say Thais fighter who
Star Wars project a Star Wars project
has lost another director what's going
on out there a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away we're gonna analyze it
today right here on fat man on Batman
that men on Batman welcome The Fatman
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I am mark barnard
okay so the other day a bunch of people
were tweeting at me you should do Star
Wars and I was like I should but I
didn't know why they were saying that I
will don't tell me what to do I'm doing
it you just wait then I want to find out
why they were saying that is because
they fired another Star Wars director
they did drop in the crime
the drop in life dies they're dropping
like [ __ ] guys that control or good
command the executioner in Empire
Strikes Back oh nice job
my [ __ ] drops and then they hire
somebody else and Piatt which would make
Kathy Kennedy I guess lord Vader
cuz this is her fourth firing she is
forced choking [ __ ] like no
tomorrow you miss she's running things
now you got everyone's like what why is
she like this it's one of the most
successful producers on the plant it's
totally she must know what she's doing
and she's in charge of the legacy she's
a charge of Star Wars and so you know
she's making decisions and cleaning
houses and apparently the latest victim
of the housecleaning is Colin Trevorrow
now this is a kid who made one picture
went to Sundance called safety 19
batteries not included that was a long
time ago safety not guaranteed and then
he got tapped to make Jurassic world
Jurassic world made a [ __ ] ton of money
1.6 billion dollars so when they
announced hey guess who's doing the Star
Wars Episode nine which I was told was
the last episode but now nobody's making
any promises
so I guess who's doing nine the kid did
to Jurassic world you go makes sense
that movie made a lot of money and [ __ ]
I guess I would have given nine to like
you know Spielberg or something like
that but they were gone and whole
different whatever so you know thing
Newburgh had tapped him for Jurassic
world he likes this kid he says I like
this kid Trevorrow he says I sees myself
in him I says I says let him do Jurassic
world that says that's what Spielberg
says yeah so you figure it all right
everything's hunky-dory everything's
gonna be great then just the other day
the big floppy dick of truth
smacks us all across the face and we
find out that another director of a Star
Wars movie has been fired mark Bernard
and take it away indeed I will read you
from some reports and now
Oh Kevin mark read other people's news
where's this coming from at least give
credit where credit's due this comes
from vulture and now the reading of the
news reading from the book of vulture
chapter 1 both your hair I like them I
saw a piece on a director I liked very
much
yeah I mean profile they did pretty well
New York magazine yeah like a diamond
but it yeah great job Abraham really he
came and watched us do this show did
when we were at the other place he's got
really good hair yeah he's got great
[ __ ] hair big shock a red hair and he
made me read about myself in a way where
I was like I like this guy and mind you
I like me a lot in the world's biggest
Kevin Smith fan so that's good
journalism there you go meanwhile
meanwhile sure were pulling this
conspiracy theory a maintains with the
book of Henri Trevorrow is critically
mauled commercially stillborn or has
passion project he he made a yoga hosers
this year he did he went for it a Dookie
he made a Dookie and people were not
pleased with it my I wouldn't have done
that I mean I know your phone maker and
you're like hey man I want to make a
movie regardless but you know I get they
gave me Star Wars and the last thing I
did was Jurassic I'm doing anything but
shut it down oh my lord the next thing I
do is Star Wars so you know he shouldn't
be punished for that but he did make a
movie that didn't do much for people and
I guess that's part of the reason
knowing yeah it gave him cold feet but
even more than the cold feet apparently
he is not the easy-going ggest
director in Hollywood no honestly swear
to God hello and suck do it again he's
not the the easygoing yes director of
Hollywood it's not worth it that tasted
too good no really yeah of all the
people in the biz I never want to put a
gun to my head no like who do you think
is an [ __ ]
I never this kid doesn't even make the
top 200 list why why is he bad guy well
there's an executive who requested
anonymity out of concern for sensitive
ongoing business relationships very
brave as one does said that during the
making of Germany Bothans died to give
us this information really it did during
the making of Jurassic world he focused
a great deal of his creative energies on
asserting his opinion the executive
explains but because he'd been
personally hired by Spielberg nobody
could
say you're fired once that film went
through the roof and he chose to do
Henry look up Henry Giroux was
unbearable
he had an egotistical point of view and
he was always asserting that then during
pre-production on Episode nine to
rehearse relationship with Lucasfilm top
brass became reportedly unmanageable
over the course of repeated stabs at
multiple drafts of the script so he was
allowed to write the script as well he's
read the script as well although at
first I think that the word had been
that Rian Johnson was gonna write eight
and nine all right look at a direct date
I guess they were hoping that he would
also direct nine but then they gave it
to tomorrow right the way it goes but
now that arrangement seems to be fallen
by the wayside if I had to guess my
feeling is they were like look we like
what Rian Johnson did with the last Jedi
he's way easy for us to work with Kathy
digs him totally why are we banging our
head against a wall we just fired two
[ __ ] directors like a minute away from
the end of the movie that's how gangster
we are you don't think we're gonna
[ __ ] like change our mind about the
guy who did Jurassic world [ __ ] it and
they dropped him like a hot rock and I
bet ryan johnson winds up directing i
think so
if not if not Ron Howard is a certainty
I think Ron Howard I mean if I had to
guess I've had to bet money on it
Ron Howard took the Han Solo job as sort
of a I'll do this for you right if you
do this for me
boy shucks I'd really like to direct
episode nine in that Ron Howard II way I
mean I guess you're an alert I'm on to
you Howard I'd like to help you out but
you got to give me something in return
all nice guy up front but back back back
room he's gays Game of Thrones
he's a Cersei and he just [ __ ] to
everything he just cocked up this hat
now he's wearing it
Ron Howard I know what you're up to
obi-wan kenobe tell Cersei I wanted her
to know I don't think I think I don't
honestly I don't know the guy but I
don't think he's gonna go it's like I'll
do this if you do this but I guarantee
you they're like oh my god we just
brought Ron in he's [ __ ] crushing it
on Han Solo we never fight with him he
does to everyone it was great job blah
blah blah why are we banging our heads
against the wall we can't get him
fighting with this kid all time [ __ ] it
life's too
or ron howard it is i could see that
happen I feel like it's definitely name
house choice it's out of Ryan because he
came in on like compare lead last Jedi
he's done wrapped in a can and that's
the thing you don't hear anything about
last Jedi other than hey it's coming
yeah and hey there new toys but you
don't hear [ __ ] like yeah they had a
problem with it somebody else directs or
bunny that [ __ ] like they're done they
didn't reshoot or anything that [ __ ]
like he seems to be a dude who was happy
to play within the lines happy to color
with the colors they told me color with
happy to color the pattern they told him
to color a little jagged here that's
fine that's fine what do you think they
meant about Colin Trevorrow talking to
me I'm Jurassic world he was opinionated
I mean I think it was him probably as a
young man asserting his what he thinks
is the role of a director is to subdue a
crew and press it into service and make
sure that everybody knows that he's a
creative you know wellspring from which
all good things flow we're supposed to
do this job not if you want to do a Star
Wars movie in order on this a so not
that [ __ ] but that [ __ ] out a job
so maybe I'm doing all right
couple [ __ ] not making Star Wars me
in column hey same boat according to a
veteran movie producer who has worked
with us with Kathy Kennedy okay there's
one gatekeeper when it comes to Star
Wars and it's Kathy okay if you rub her
the wrong way in any way you're out
you're done a lot of these young new
directors want to come in and say I want
to do this I want to do that a lot of
these guys Lord and Miller Colin
Trevorrow got very rich very fast and
believed a lot of their own hype and
they don't want to play by the rules
they want to do [ __ ] differently and
Kathy Kennedy isn't going to [ __ ] around
with that you're fired
[ __ ] man I got daya's some of the
goings-on in the making of Star Wars oh
man almost as galactic and epic as the
events we see on the [ __ ] screen
there have almost been more fired
directors of Star Wars movies and there
have been Star Wars movies she is
literally just Darth Vader snapping a
[ __ ] lightsaber on a dark hallway and
choking [ __ ] and cutting him
over her head Dyson and his license
julienne frying yep the director the
director in community now there are two
schools of thought on this
hey man Star Wars is her she gets to do
whatever she wants and that's what I you
know she's put in charge turns and she's
doing great job he's knows what she's
doing but then there's no school of
thought that's like you don't hire a
director and then [ __ ] harness the
director but in these movies yeah you do
yeah honestly these movies occur to me
the same way that Supergirl I just came
off of you know it's not Colin it's not
a Colin Trevorrow I'm directing Star
Wars Episode nine dick but I've directed
Supergirl a few times and I was just up
there recently
you know what would suck for everybody
involved actors crew the producers down
in Los Angeles CW the network if I went
in and start telling people you know my
opinion is this whole [ __ ]
should be one take black and white a lot
of cocksuck talked like they'd be like
dude that ain't a [ __ ] show you go
into somebody's already existing thing
you got to make their thing like it's
not simple if you don't Star Wars go I'm
like I got a vision they had that vision
back in 77 and all they want to do is
make that vision today same vision
they've been having for a long time so
you come into that place you're not
being invited in because they're like we
think you've got brilliant ideas they're
like you got a name you're we like what
you did and stuff like that but when you
come here you're playing by different
rules you can't walk in there and expect
me who you were when you made your film
for them I mean it's like if you want to
go to write like I don't [ __ ] know if
I'm Colin Trevorrow right now watching
this like [ __ ] you silent bill like you
even know what goes on in Star Wars you
fat PZ [ __ ] what I would suggest you
watch book of Henry in common
who I mean you've written creator-owned
books before you've written
company-owned books before there's a
bunch of [ __ ] you can do if you're
writing green arrow that has to follow
the rules yes like this character has to
do a B and C like you've got creativity
within the boundaries yes where there
are boundaries this is work for hire
this is not you're coming in to execute
your own creative vision it's somebody
else's vision that you being hired to
execute very true and also let's be fair
we read an article that was in vulture
of some cat won't even give his name
going like this guy's an [ __ ] so
nobody knows maybe he's a [ __ ] Prince
Valiant he's a righteous [ __ ] dude
and stuff maybe he just had a very very
strict belief on what he thought this
movie should be in a conflicted with the
boss and that's that's the way the
cookie crumbles again they're not gonna
choose you over her and you know what
don't kill you to get kicked off a Star
Wars film like Lord Miller gonna be fine
josh trank it was kicked off a Star Wars
film that didn't even exist yet he's off
directing Tom Hardy in a movie right now
so things are gonna everything's coming
up millhouse for colin trevorrow to
publish about tomorrow I love that dress
world movie a lot of people gave me [ __ ]
about that too I was like I [ __ ] love
it oh my god it reminds me of my
childhood and people like [ __ ] you it's
a rehash and blah blah blah that's why I
thought he was a great choice yeah
episode 9 it's like all right this guy
reverently dealt with you know the de
Franchi eyes exists to be for him stuff
[ __ ] didn't work out I mean I think you
know we talked about it before I think
Ron Howard is a good choice I think
Brian Schatz would be a great choice I
think Ava Duvernay would be a great
choice we were talking about we've text
back and forth going who would you do
would you do tell him why you think Ava
would be great I mean I stole your
choice when I tweeted the other day I
was like yeah I'm gonna drop this Ava so
good but yeah she just she's rapping
she's finishing post-production i
wrinkle of time this thing is very happy
and the testing is huge the testing is
huge is through the roof and people for
years been saying why not a woman
directing star will know Kathy has come
under a little bit of flak for out of
all these movies she's had to find
directors for she's never tapped a woman
for it she is an incredibly attractive
choice on almost every one of those
those values kills a lot of boxes get
ticked a lot of boxes get ticked so
they're a great choice but there's
really good at her job
I went lame and said of course James
Gunn who I'm a big fan of those
guardians movies which have the [ __ ]
they're like Star Wars on sugar you know
just like fun I also suggested Steven
Spielberg because why not like heavens
look he's been around since this all
started and stuff ever on the you know
outskirts but why not give him one and
then I or why not let Lucas finish off
his epic and the Internet that's a much
put a big fat dick in my mouth they were
like are you great three reasons Jar Jar
begs they kept saying and stuff so a lot
of people were against the idea I don't
know I felt like the idea of somebody
tweeted like oh I get it
redemption narrative I was like yeah
yeah like after everyone gave him [ __ ]
about those last three if he makes nine
and it [ __ ] crushed and stuff you
know all's forgiven boy whatever people
don't want to see this a lot of it is
crazy dude a lot of people like he had
his chance and it's like he made that
[ __ ] he did like he had his chance when
the audience thinks they control the
thing it's gonna be a little weird
though like I'll have to say he got
fired from his job but he abdicated the
throne and when then show up is like a
minor Duke
woody be a minor Duke though he'd be the
one guy that like you know Kathy Kenny
would be like do what you want carte
blanche although if Kathy Kennedy would
have to fire George Lucas clearly she's
a fire and lady then then you shoot that
cuz that's Star Wars right there - Spig
stars having a big old wall I mean would
be delicious to have to talk about but I
can't I can't even imagine for a second
that George puts themselves in those
crosshairs how often you think this used
to happen we just didn't hear about it I
mean I'm not gonna say all the time
because there were there were not
superstar director well think about it
Richard Donner was kicked off of
Superman - right it's a handful of times
but like not at this rate of regularity
well they spent how much buying it for
billion loaded Star Wars so they gotta
make all that money back and I can't
believe they haven't done that already
at this point all right so that's what
they want to do and that's what they're
gonna do
News that's what they want so let them
have it as well it looks like from the
outside we don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] I
got no inside scoop I wish I've no
budding [ __ ] so we're just two guys from
the outside [ __ ] reading vulture and
casting conjecture I feel bad for Colin
Trevorrow I feel bad for anybody gets
[ __ ] fired high-profile like that
especially because like the Machine
seems to go right into work and people
like well you know that guy he was rough
and I'd never heard anything like that
before but to be fair I don't really
have my ear to the ground going who
who's tough in this business would
[ __ ] yeah I just I spend most of my
time trying not to be a Hollywood
[ __ ] so I'm not trying to find out
who there's the also shit's way above my
pay grade
I'm a guy watch the Star Wars man I
don't even let me in on these guys so we
don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] but no my
heart goes out to Colin's rargh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] sucks get fired from any
job let alone everyone where everyone's
like hey man good good on you you got a
Star Wars movie yeah everybody knows and
then [ __ ] a year later like hey man
you want to talk about it like this he's
got carry this like luggage for the next
like year and [ __ ] and when the movie
comes out hmm could have been yours what
a Lord and Miller doing next do they
know yet yeah man announce it yet nope
it's huge there's talk of you know going
back to the flesh which they could that
would make me happy all right there you
got there you got it folks can't say
anything more about the situation
because we really don't know anything no
I mean we can make some more [ __ ] up but
do you really need that it's the
Internet plenty of people are making
[ __ ] up
there's conjecture elsewhere here's
where you get the facts and we pull our
facts from Bulger and the Internet yeah
um so there it is again
take you know we don't know if Colin
Trevorrow is a good gonna I look I'm
relatively sure he's killed no one so
that makes him relatively good guess far
as I know but unfortunately he ain't
getting direct Star Wars nope no galaxy
far away do you know what I'm doing
today in honor of poor Colin Trevor what
do you do I'm watching book Henry oh
yeah yeah [ __ ] it
somebody should
as a real stand in Holly moment there's
another fine mess you've gotten us into
yeah man well everybody gets to yoga as
Emma says unfortunately [ __ ] to this
chance to do Star Wars whoops Yipes so
I'm gonna watch that movie everybody if
you feel bad for this poor kid lost a
movie and [ __ ]
mmm check out his book it's book Henry's
book Andy not Book of Eli that's
actually not half bad
I was with Denzel washing your imight
watch that too you should do there's
gonna be a book up day I'm watching a
book up double feature look at it
cooking it man all right there it is
we're done talking about pretty of those
problems back to her own hmm thanks for
hanging out with us here in the fat cave
ladies and gentlemen for fat man on
Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Oprah come in next episode come in
come on in next episode we'll save a
seat for you here won't you be our
neighbor same fad time same bat Channel
smoky ska more youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you